Rihanna and ASAP Rocky serve Fierce
fashion during a date night at the Black
Panther wakanda forever premiere
the singer who lends her voice to the
film's soundtrack dazzled in a sparkling
Rick Owens dress with accented long
gloves and the rapper well he perfectly
matches his lady love in a similar look
Rihanna's appearance comes one day after
announcing her musical comeback yes
you're still gonna get music from me yup
she followed through giving fans a new
original song titled Lift Me Up set to
be the lead single for the superhero
flick sequel she gifted the Navy with
this small tease
[Laughter]
and Riri she couldn't be any prouder to
be a part of it
I'm honored to be a part of this
[Music]
and the ladies of wakanda they're just
as excited to have Riri in the Black
Panther Family if I knew oh my goodness
I would retire I have no idea how it
happened but I'm glad it happened and I
look forward to hearing what she has
uh gifted this uh this story I haven't
heard it yeah black women are being
empowered and black women are being
celebrated
um for all their beauty for their
intelligence and all that they are so
November 11th I didn't know that was
going to happen
love
yeah I'm like I'm still processing that
she smiled at me and black panther
director Ryan coogler is also singing
riri's praises she is a big one man she
is she is the one and only coogler
doesn't know why ree felt compelled to
do it but he's ecstatic she did she's a
a person who marches to the beat of Her
Own Drum I'm just thankful that she she
wanted to she wanted to contribute to
this you know and I'll be very grateful
and and not just her you know but all
the other fantastic musicians that that
that are on the soundtrack Rihanna was
one of the writers of the track which is
a tribute to The Life and Legacy of late
actor Chadwick Boseman
and honoring Chadwick was important to
the cast and crew including his
on-screen mother Angela Bassett
how are you feeling today mama
your father and I will talk about this
day all the time you know we loved him
and we we know that you love him and we
would not we will honor that we honor it
for the fans as well as for ourselves
you know as well as for ourselves it was
very important that we that we we
recognize we recognize and we couldn't
we couldn't do it without him
[Music]
now one time
show them
before we started one frame shot one
frame we all gathered together at this
resting place and we you know we his
name to the heavens and we smiled and
we're with his family it was a beautiful
experience because it was it's too
painful otherwise but when we lean into
the love that we have for him the
respect the regard and as a feeling
people you know as a people who know
that death is not the end we know that
he was on that set with us every day
whispering to us go on do your best be
excellent
foreign